[Musique]
mais
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip sur le
plateau de tv 78 nous avons aujourd'hui
et n jacob qui est un et qui est un
auteur journaliste
enquête sur la famille mystérieuse
communauté religieuse c'est le nom de
son ouvrage et il sera présent au salon
histoire de lire avec sigh le 20
novembre voilà et ian jacobs bonjour
bonjour merci de m'avoir invité merci
d'être venus voilà vous avez écrit un
ouvrage absolument passionnant si vous
voilà sur une on peut pas dire une secte
d'une communauté religieuse une
communauté religieuse
mystérieuse voilà vous êtes journaliste
au figaro quel est votre secteur
d'action au figaro bah je serai beaucoup
des dérives sectaires c'est un domaine
qui m'a toujours intéressé je trouve ça
passionnant de ce qu'on est dans le le
cacher le mystérieux l'étranger c'est
toujours passionnant qu'est ce qu'il
vous plaît alors comment vous est venue
cette idée d'enquêté sur cette fameuse
communauté qui s'appelle la famille va
écouter les anciens de la famille donc
des personnes qui sont parties de cette
communauté qui ont réussi à s'en sortir
avait créé un groupe facebook et ils ont
dénoncé les abus les abus sexuels les
dérives en dix ans pour pour le coup que
c'était une secte donc moi ça m'a vite
intéressé j'ai voulu enquêter là dessus
j'ai fait un article pour le figaro
magazine meed dans cet article comme on
en avait pas assez dit il fallait
enquêter et pendant plus d'un an j'ai
enquêté des reportages de terrain des
interviews des témoignages pour
convaincre les personnes de la famille
de parler témoigne de ta part et cette
communauté est d'accord alors déjà on va
expliquer un peu en quoi cela consiste
donc cette fameuse famille
aujourd'hui il ya combien de membres ont
environ 4000 membres d'accord et elle
existe depuis combien de temps cette
communauté a été fondée en
et mais ce qu'on le point principal de
cette famille c'est la date principal
c'est 1892 en fait il y à un des
prophètes de cette famille qui
s'appelait l'oncle ho must qui est donc
voilà effectivement quelques elle alors
je crois que c'est dû à gauche
avec la casquette est en fait il a il
était très influent et il a décidé de
fermer cette famille sur le monde
extérieur donc sa famille à lui ouais en
fait il y avait déjà il avait décidé
donc quelques années plus tard cesser
ses grands parents avaient décidé de
marier leurs enfants entre eux mais des
personnes arrivées c'est à dire qu'on
pouvait rentrer dans la connerie il
ajouté il faut que ça se faisait à
l'époque des mariages arrangés voilà et
lui il a décidé de fermer sa en limitant
du coup à 9 patronyme y en a un qui a
disparu dont aucun n'a plus que huit
aujourd'hui d'emblée il a dit il y aura
neuf patronyme point barre au départ il
ya eu neuf patronyme pas encore toutes
ces années il lui a dit on va faire mais
maintenant on arrête de faire venir des
personnes parce que ça s'est pas bien
passé donc on se ferme et il a établi
tout un tas de règles très strictes les
femmes pouvaient pas porter de pantalon
il n'était pas possible pour elles de
danser les enfants étaient faisait
l'école à la maison
ces règles ont été édictées par par
l'oncle augustin l'oncle auguste qui
étaient très strictes à ce soit d'accord
et alors du coup aujourd'hui vous dites
qu'il y à 4000 membres comment on peut
les
répertorier ces gens comme montpellier
ou est-ce qu'on peut les retrouver à
côté ils sont dans le xième le douzième
le 20e arrondissement et petit à petit
le temps passe en sachant que les loyers
sont sont chères excéder les familles
qui vivent de peu leurs règles une des
règles édictées justement par le parlant
que l'auguste et de dire qu' on ne va
pas faire de travail qui qui rapporte
énormément d'argent
donc en vivement en vivant pieusement
finalement
on a 7 7 7 cette communauté qui s'est un
peu décalé dans des villes comme
montreuil vincennes de l'est parisot
dans l'est mais là où les loyers sont un
peu moins cher ce soir parce que les
études sont arrêtés à 16 ans alors
c'était c'était une des règles édictées
par l'anc auguste ça a tendance un peu à
se détendre mais effectivement les les
enfants ne font pas toujours de longues
études
la miviludes qui est la mission
interministérielle gouvernementale qui
qui qui traitent des dérives sectaires
et justement à effet une note de
vigilance en 2017 en disant que la
condition des enfants posent des
questions parce que les enfants il
vivait un peu dans un carcan dans un
bocal et ils n'ont pas toutes les
possibilités que pourrait avoir un
enfant dans une famille classique
d'accord parce qu'en fait maintenant il
n'y a pas forcément décollé à la maison
aujourd'hui ils émettent à l'école
communale comme tout le monde mais vu
qu'ils habitent tous les à côtés des
autres finalement ils doivent avoir 25
juin à l'école on est d'accord voilà si
vous habitez dans les eaux si vous avez
grandi dans les 11e 12e 20e
arrondissement vous êtes sûr que vous
connaissez les patronymes de la famille
il y en avait plusieurs dans votre
collège dans votre lycée c'est ça qui
est assez impressionnant
il ya même des groupes facebook ont été
créées vous avez tous connu un faire un
sanglier 1 100 dos et les noms de cette
famille voilà un petit bout qui qui ont
qui ont grandi dans dans ces
arrondissements là donc oui sont l'école
à la maison c'est plus quelque chose qui
se fait mais il ya quand même quand
encore certaines familles un peu plus
rigoriste dans les voiles avancer même
degré de voilà selon le foyer ça change
en fait mais mais encore certains font
l'écho la maison mais c'est très rare
très rare mais on a l'impression que de
toute façon ces enfants ces gens quand
ils sont enfants ils sont tellement le
carcan est tellement fort que finalement
leur prison il a transporté avec eux
c'est ça c'est ça c'est que c'est une
qu'un risque l'emprise mentale se fait
dès la naissance contrairement à une
secte où finalement on est embrigadé à
n'importe quel âge là en fait le
l'embrigadement il se fait dès la
naissance alors certains vivent très
heureux dans la famille c'est ça qu'il
faut parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de voir ce qu'est le monde
extérieur alors justement ils n'ont pas
la possibilité de voir le monde
extérieur ok mais qu'est ce qui se passe
à l'adolescence quand il commença à
rouen entre guillemets dans les
brancards ouais ça c'est un phénomène
que j'ai observé avec les dons les
nombreux témoins que j'ai pu interroger
c'est qu'en fait très souvent à
l'adolescence on laisse ainsi on donne
un petit peu de lest les adolescents
leur dit allez vivre va vivre son
premier amour et malheureusement le
premier amour se passe souvent pas très
bien c'est souvent la famille dit ben
regarde voici ce qui va se passer si tu
vas vers l'extérieur si tu explores le
monde et ça c'est assez assez par
messieurs c'est complètement pervers
c'est assez pervers et mais c'est une
tactique qui fonctionne bien parce que
du coup souvent les ados se disent ah
oui d'accord mais du coup j'ai peut-être
plutôt trouver la personne que j'aime au
sein de la famille ça du local qu'à me
disent ah c'est ça sinon ce sont des
poissons rouges chez une personne de la
famille qui avait fait 1 qui a fait un
roman sunu alias s'appelait françois
louis est spacieuse eliès bassoues souci
d'un carton jaune
moi je dis c'est sous pseudo qui
disaient qu'ils parlaient de bocal
justement un samedi très bien ce que
c'est ça c'est vivre dans un carcan avec
un peu d eau iard complètement et alors
les femmes les pauvres alors elles sont
vouées à rester à la maison elles
s'avèrent travail et s'occuper des
enfants les enfants nombreux très
souvent des enfants nombreux parce que
évidemment pas de contraception au sein
de la famille dont on a
régulièrement des familles de dix
enfants 12 enfants j'ai pu contacter des
spécialistes de santé qui font à coup
chez les femmes de la famille qui
n'accouche pas la maison mais qui
accouchent en maternité oui c'est son
problème mais frotte au monde entre
guillemets normal quand même voilà
gilles il aime bien dire qu'ils vivent à
côté du monde il abaisse à l'extérieur
non l'agente solide et l'extérieur les
gentils l'itc quoi c'est le monde
extérieur qu'ils appellent aussi
l'extérieur voilà ok mais
par exemple quelqu'un qui part de la
famille qui réussit à sandra sont moins
son dépêtrer on y reviendra peut-être il
est parti dans le monde d'accord alors
ben justement à losique louis alors donc
consanguinité j'imagine consanguinité on
se marie entre cousins partenaires
cousins germains cause des problèmes
évidemment pathologique on a des
maladies qui se développent et notamment
le syndrome de bloom qui est un syndrome
très rare une personne sur un million la
trappe après en france est en fait dans
la famille on en aurait peut-être 10 20
30 qui l'aurait c'est un syndrome qui se
caractérise par le fait d'être être
atteint de nanisme alala et des joues
rouges en fait donc c'est un le problème
c'est qu'en fait ça a provoqué des
cancers on peut très vite attrapé des
cancers avec cette maladie là on ne vit
pas très vieux on attrape tout les
maladies possibles donc c'est assez
problématique et personne ne leur dit
rien les médecins quand ils ont un
gynéco qui a accouché pour la douzième
fois madame thibout on lui dit pas enfin
même pas les lire un peu avant mais bon
faut pas empêcher les gens de
d'accoucher à signaler c'est sa gamme de
consoles je pense que nous ne nous font
pas diagnostiquer cette maladie en tout
cas parce que ça ne te guardian
s'inventer voilà parce que l'institut
curie qui est le seul institut en france
qui s'occupe de cette maladie ne sais
pas et savent pas mais ça ne s'est pas
que il ya une communauté qui
potentiellement des membres ont 7 7
photo logique faudrait avertir il faudra
leur dire je leur ai dit mais
il tombait des nues ont valeur très bien
oui c'est complètement fou qu'on parle
de code que maintenant c'est ça ils sont
restés secrets sous les radars ils sont
passés sous les radars finalement c'est
vrai qu'il ya quand même quelques
similarités par rapport à des familles
juifs orthodoxes traite donc j'imagine
que dans les quartiers des 11e 20e 2e
arrondissement se disait bien il ya une
grande famille et c'est ce que disent
les personnes qui sont allées à l'école
l'huile est d'une grande famille il
vient un peu différemment parce que
souvent les les présente les jeunes
filles j'ai un témoignage incroyable
d'une dune d'une femme qui me parlait de
cantat était à l'école avec une jeune
fille de la famille elle faisait sa
liste de courses parce que c'est elle
qu'il devait faire une course pourtant
été elle avait 13 14 ans mais voilà elle
était même plus petit que ça d'ailleurs
même à l'école primaire et c'est vrai
qu'il y avait une sorte de
responsabilisation de
financement qui est impressionnant après
vingt trois ans après fallait car ajoute
qu'il couche et lait maternisé ce sur sa
vie du coussin de courtes donc fallait
castrais pas dites moi comment on peut
en sortir si on veut en sortir ben on
peut en sortir donc ça c'est peut-être
une caractéristique d'un peu différent
d'une d'une secte
habituelles voilà
mais malheureusement quand vous avez
grandi uniquement avec des personnes qui
sont vos cousins quand vous allez partir
ils vont certainement vous renier donc
vous allez tout seul est le traître
voilà vous êtes le traite vous êtes mal
vu au début on va essayer de vous
récupérer c'est à dire qu'on va
peut-être vous dans la rue on va
regarder vous qu'ils habitent ces
personnes habitent dans le même quartier
voilà ils sont des regards mais mais on
se retrouve du jour au lendemain ces
personnes peuvent se retrouver du jour
au lendemain seul et j'ai un témoignage
d'une personne qui m'a dit qu'elle s'est
retrouvée sdf du jour au lendemain à
cause de son départ de la famille parce
que quand on parle de la famille souvent
c'est parce qu'on a trouvé l'amour aïe
aïe aïe leur carrière voilà et vu qu'on
peut pas on ne peut pas intégrer cette
personne dans la famille ben on s'en bat
d'accord
et alors autant il existe une solidarité
dans cette famille s'il y en a qui ont
des problèmes de sous il ya une cagnotte
qui et voilà ils sont tous un peu ce
sera un cocon pourquoi est ce qu'il n'y
ait pas une cagnotte pour ceux qui
veulent partir n'existait pas parce que
justement partir c'est non mais créé par
ceux qui sont passés à l'extérieur ah
oui oui effectivement à les écouter je
pense que les personnes qui sont parties
ont quant elles ont créé ce groupe
facebook justement pour dénoncer mais la
ligue en ces termes c'est une façon de
se dire voilà on va enfin se réunir se
reparler il ya des personnes qui sont
parties depuis des dizaines d'années qui
se sont re parler grâce à ce groupe là
on se retrouve finalement parce que
quand les personnes sont parties de la
famille elles sont elles vivent du coup
vraiment à l'écart de toutes ces
familles mais les autres personnes qui
sont parties ne sont pas forcément par
ne se sont pas forcément parler entre
elles sur les trouver sa voix grave et
moins bien organisés c'est ça voilà
écouter et à votre avis ça va durer
encore longtemps cette affaire parce que
la consanguinité les réelles au bout
d'un moment oui alors tout sept nains
avec des joues rouges toutes les alors
évidemment cette maladie et elle est
quand même rare donc si ça concerne 20
ou 30 personnes sur 4000 tr wima la
majorité mais mes skis et ski et ski
évident la dernière question ce qui est
évident c'est que c'est que la famille
va certainement perdurer même oui alors
je pense que par exemple m'a dit la
médiatisation a certainement eu un
impact
local positif c'est le par exemple le
fait de plus trop se marier entre
cousins germains qu'ils ont pris
conscience de ça ils ont pris conscience
qu'il y avait qui avait des problèmes et
je pense que ça va peut-être permettre
un relâchement mais aussi la
médiatisation vu que eux attendent la
fin du monde coutts et ce alors voilà il
atteindra fanion sont des frondes sont
des fondamentalistes chrétiens il il
estime que que tout ce qui se passe dans
le monde est une raison de parler d'eux
lors de cette fin du monde oui voilà
sept ans des pis ça va très mal ce
paraphe façon ça va s'arrêter bientôt
voilà c'est ça et la médiatisation
c'était prévu pour eux et c'est synonyme
que que la fin du monde est proche est à
mon avis ça aussi resserrer les rangs au
sein des plus rigoristes bon d'écouter
avant la fin du monde retrouve on
retrouve où nous nous retrouverons au
salon histoire de lire à versailles jean
bafouille ce livre passionnant voilà je
le recommande c'est c'est étonnant et
passionnant fascinant bravo pour ce
travail merci et à très vite pour de
nouvelles enquêtes et sienne jacob la
seule au revoir à tous merci de nous
avoir suivi et à très vite ans
[Musique]